بالرغم من كون بولندا في طليعه الدول
الداعمه لاوكرانيا ومن ابرز مزوديها
بالاسلحه الا ان الخلافات حول صادرات
الحبوب دفعت وارسو الى اتخاذ موقف جديد
توقفنا عن نقل الاسلحه الى اوكرانيا لاننا
نقوم الان بتصليح بولندا باسلحه اكثر حدثا
الخارجيه البولنديه استدعت من جهتها
السفيره الاوكراني احتجاجا على تصريحات
الرئيس بروديوميرزنسكي في الامم المتحده
واتهامه دولا معينه بدعم روسيا بشكل غير
مباشر
نريد مساعده اوكرانيا بالقدر الذي يصب في
مصلحه بولندا ولا حرج في ذلك اذا كانت
هنالك خلافات في الراي بين القاده فيجب ان
نتحدث عنها وعدم اتخاذ اجراءات غير
المبرره فهذه الكلمات مؤلمه جدا لملايين
البولنديين الذين ساعدوا اوكرانيا
واللاجئين الاوكرانيين لذلك لا ينبغي قول
مثل هذه الكلمات
حده التوتر بين وارسو وكيا ارتفعت مؤخرا
بسبب حظر بولندا واردات الحبوب الاوكرانيه
لحمايه مزارعيها خاصه وان الناخبين في
المناطق الزراعيه هم من ابرز داعمي
الحكومه اليمينيه الحاليه التي تستعد لخوض
الانتخابات التشريعيه الشهر المقبل